تحدث الرئيس الاوكراني فودون ارسالنسكي ان
العام 20 23 سيكون عام النصر وبنظره الى
الاحداث مع انطلاقه العام يبدو ان البدايه
مبشرا لاوكرانيين اسلحه متطوره امريكيه
وغربيه في الطريق الى كياف صمود وضربات
ثقيله ضد الجيش الروسي على جبهات القتال
وتوحد غربي مستمر على ضروره دعم اوكرانيا
وتعثر عسكري متكرر للقوات الروسيه طبعا
اذا استمر عام 20 23 كما بدا بحسب صحيفه
واشنطن بوست فهناك فرصه جيده لان تتمكن
اوكرانيا من الوفاء بتعهد الرئيسكيل العام
الجديد باستعاده كل اوكرانيا بحلول نهايه
العام او على الاقل مساحه كافيه لانهااء
التهديد الروسي بشكل نهائي
لكن على الجبهه المقابله يستغل الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين خطابات العام
الجديد لاعداد الروس لخوض معركه طويله
الامل مع زياده التحصينات وتعزيز بمئه الف
جندي روسي تم حسدهم حديثا امر سيزيد من
صعوبه المهمه على اوكرانيا وتحقيق تقدم في
سيزيد من صعوبه تحقيق تقدم اكثر من ما كان
عليه في العام الماضي رغم ان الخبراء
العسكريين يقولون ان الزخمه من الانتصارات
الاخيره يتصاحب
[موسيقى]
تنقل واشنطن بوست عن شكل فورد من مجلس
شيكاغو لشؤون العالميه قولها انه اذا لم
تتمكن من تحقيق اختراقات كبيره ضد القوه
الروسيه الراسخه والمتناميه فهناك خطر ان
تتحول الحرب الى صراع طويل الامد يصب في
صالح بوتن بينما يرى
القائد السابق للجيش الامريكي في اوروبا
ان التطورات في الاسبوع الاول من العام
تشير الى ان الافاق مشرقه بالنسبه الى
اوكرانيا مشيرا الى ان ضربه مكيفك القاسيه
التي قتلت 89 جنديا روسيا بحسب وزاره
الدفاع موسكو يضيف او يقول ان ذلك دليل او
ان هذه الضربه دليل على ما يتفضل
يضيف بانه طالما ظل الدعم الغربي قويا فان
هو واثق من ان اوكرانيا يمكنها استعاده كل
او معظم الاراضي التي احتلتها روسيا هذا
العام بما في ذلك شبه جزيره القرم التي
احتلتها روسيا عام 2014 توقعات تبدو
متفائله بل متفائله الى حد كبير
عام 20 22 في جزء منها الى سذاجه الاخطاء
الروسيه التي من غير المرجح ان تتكرر الان
فيقول خبير عسكري ان الدفاع اسهل من
الهجوم وقد اقام الروس بالفعل مواقع
دفاعيه طويله اضف الى ذلك ان كثافه
الذخيره قد تنخفض من الطرفين وليس من
الجانب الاوكراني فقط فهناك ادله مستمره
على انخفاض الامدادات الروسيه ايضا
مسؤولون اوكرانيون قالوا مؤخرا ان معدل
نيران المدفعيه الروسيه على طول الجبهه
الشرقيه لا يتجاوز الان ثلث ما كان عليه
خلال الصيف ونقلت واشنطن بوست عن مسؤول
غربي تحدث شريطه عدم الك عن هويه لمناقشه
مسائل امنيه حساسه يقول انه رغم ان روسيا
امرت بتصنيع مكثف فمن الواضح ان الانتاج
الروسي لن يكون قادرا على مجاراه
الاستهلاك
ونتابع من ما يقوله مسؤول عسكري امريكي
الان تحديدا لا مؤشرات على التدخل بلا
روسيا في الحرب بل انها تكتفي بالتدريبات
لكن رغم هذا توقع ديمتري البروج وفيتش
رئيس مركز سيلفيرادو بول سياكل ريتر وهو
مركز ابحاث مقر واشنطن ان تكون اوكرانيا
قادره على استعاده بعض الاراضي هذا العام
ولكن ليس بما يكفي لتامين نصر النهائي
الحرب ليست عسكريه فقط بل هناك جانب
اقتصادي مهم وحاسم الاقتصادي الروسي او
الاقتصابان الروسي والاكراني سيتعرضان
لضغوط شديده بمواجهه حرب طويله ومن غير
واضح اذا كان بامكان كل دوله توليد ما
يكفي من القوه البشريه لخوض تلك المعركه
حرب طويله اذا من شانها ان تؤجل الى اجل
غير مسمى تعافي اوكرانيا وسيتعين على
الحكومه الاحتفاظ بمئات الالاف من القوات
على الطول بخط المواجهه الذي يقدر بحوله
1000 كلم بينما يستمر الاقتصاد في انهيار
يعول الاوكرانيون وحلفائهم في الغرب على
شيء ما ربما يحدث في موسكو يقول هاتجيز ان
هناك بعض الصراعات الخطيره على السلطه في
موسكو بينما يرى البروفيتش انه بل يرى انه
رغم عدم وجود دليل فوري على اي تحدي لقبضه
بوتن الا ان ظهور معارضه كبيره في موسكو
قد يكون حاسما